i don't know what the hell they were
thinking
[Music]
hey what's up y'all it's michael and
i've brought my family back to try
more hummuses and this time we are
having cocktails
so we all love a good cocktail and we
love hamos but i don't know how we're
gonna feel about a mixture of the two so
we're gonna see
the first one we're gonna try is a
strawberry daiquiri hummus as somebody
who has made
strawberry jamos this is really not good
i'm sorry i flop
i think i have some credibility here
it's got a faint
strawberry smell it almost has like a
vinegar undertone
it looks like the pink drywall that you
get the cover holes
just maybe like baby food it also looks
kind of like
a melted brain it's camp
[Music]
cardboard
it is nasty it tastes like paint smells
i don't hate it there's definitely no
garlic like my strawberry jam
i just don't want it i have to give this
a three out of ten i would give the
strawberry daiquiri homeless a
one out of ten i do not taste strawberry
in that at
all i would give it a one out of ten i
don't know what the hell they were
thinking
all right we got my favorite flavor the
pina colada me personally
not a fan of pina colada in general i'm
actually kind of scared for this one
we're gonna see what this tastes like
it's like well you have to put your nose
right in there
it's really hard to get a smell kind of
has a citrusy smell
it smells not very strong in this it
smells like old pineapples
texture is actually like traditional
hamas not
so we'll see how this one is
oh my god
oh i cannot even tell you what the
flavor is of this
you know how you got to wrap a dog's
medicine and treats
this tastes like the white amoxicillin i
used to take when i would get ear
infections
all the time as a kid that is literally
what this almost tastes like
when they take you off with the pink one
because you're not a baby anymore
oh my goodness i'm gonna eat another
cracker to clean my mouth out
it is not good at all that's a zero i
won't even give that one i'll give this
a negative five out of ten
i'm gonna give it a two and i need a
palette cleanser right now
the next homeless we have is mudslide it
smells like coffee
smells like chocolate which is exciting
because i don't think i've ever had a
mudslide
according to my mom and my brother it's
kahlua and some other stuff i'm actually
not a big fan of like creamy alcohol
drinks though
i just feel like those are two things i
don't want to mix based off of
stories i cannot tell my mother right
now so
nor does my mother want to hear them
again it looks like
like spackle like drywall paste like i
hate to say this but like a grayish
brownish color it's kind of like pudding
let's try it
okay that's not bad
actually has like a coffee flavor to it
which actually would mimic the kahlua
and cream
not bad not great but it's better than
the strawberry daiquiri
i i don't hate it and i think it would
actually be really good with like maybe
like um
like a biscoff cookie or something like
that and it's like protein like
it's healthy if i were to rate this on a
scale of one to ten
i would probably give it a five i would
give this a
six out of ten i would probably give
this a four
just because it does have like that
coffee flavor
that mimics the shot but that's about it
if you and your friends are having
cocktails
and you want to try something new with
each other and have that
experience you know as it it could be a
good drinking game
and now you see where my bad influence
comes from
you